حياكم الله كشفت محطه سي ان ان الامريكيه
نقلا عن مسؤولين غربيين بان ايران تستعد
لارسال المزيد من المسيرات والصواريخ
لروسيا ياتي ذلك بعد ساعات من اقرار وزير
الخارجيه الايرانيه حسين امير عبد الاهيان
بان بلاده زودت روسيا بمسيرات لكنه قال ان
ذلك تم قبل الحرب في اوكرانيا عبد الوليان
اضاف انه اذا ثبت ان روسيا استخدمت
المسيرات الايرانيه في الحرب
فسيكونوا لبلاده حينها ردت فعل اتجاه ذلك
حسب تعبيره
التي بداتها بعض الدول الغربيه قائله ان
ايران زودت روسيا بالصواريخ والطائره بدون
طيار لمساعدتها في الحرب في اوكرانيا
الصاروخي خاطئ تماما وجزء الطائره بدون
طيار صحيح لقد قدمنا عددا محدودا من
الطائره المسيره لروسيا قبل اشهر من حرب
اوكرانيا اتفقنا مع وزير الخارجيه
الاوكرانيه على ان يقدم لنا اي ل للديهم
حول استخدام روسيا لطائرات بدون طيار
ايرانيه في اوكرانيا
تمريكوليبا ان السلطات كيف تنتظروا استلام
منظومات الدفاع جوي جديده والدفاع صاروخين
قبل نهايه العام كل بقى اضاف انا لدى
بلاده مبدا يتلخص في عدم التعليق على
عمليات التوريد حتى تعلن عنها الدول التي
تقوم بذلك مؤكدا ان هناك اتفاقات تم توصل
اليها بالفعل فيما يتعلق بانظمات الدفاع
الجوي مع بعض البلدان
من باريس ينضم علينا المحلل السياسي رمي
الخليفه العلي سيد رامي مرحبا بك معي في
نشره الرابعه من الرياض ااا وزير الخارجيه
الايراني قال بانه اذا ثبت ان روسيا
استخدمت هذه المسيرات الايرانيه التي بيعت
كما يقول الى روسيا قبل الحرب فستكون هناك
رده فعل اتجاه هذا الامر هل تعني رده فعل
هذه بان ايران تستعد لارسال المزيد من
المسيرات كما نقلت سي ان ان برايك
اهلا بك يا نايف تحيه لك ولمشاهدك الكرام
باعتقاد نعم لا اعتقد بان هنالك رده فعل
سلبيه يمكن ان تتخذها طهران اتجاه الجانب
الروسي خصوصا ان هناك تنسيق على اكثر من
مستوى وفي اكثر من ساحه سواء في سوريا او
في مناطق اخرى في مستوى على مستوى المنطقه
وبالتالي لا اعتقد ان هنالك رده فعل سلبيه
او اا منع لتصدير هذه الطائرات المسيره او
حتى لنوعيه اسلحه اخرى الى اجانب الروسي
وبالتالي الغرب بشكل عام الاتحاد الاوروبي
وكذلك الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ينظرون
الى ان طهران من خريطه بشكل كامل
بالتحالف مع الجانب الروسي وبالتالي سواء
تصدير الطائرات المسيره او حتى يمكن ان
نرى صواريخ بالستيه همم قامت في تطويرها
ايران خلال الفتره الماضي يمكن ان نرى كل
ذلك بيد القوات الروسيه تستخدمها خلال
الفتره القادمه وايران تذهب بعيدا في
مسانده اجانب الروسي في هذه الحرب على
الصعيد الغربي ينظر الى ايران بانها اصبحت
طرف في هذا الصراع وان كان بشكل غير مباشر
وبالتالي يمكن ان نتوقع زياده في حده
الخطاب اتجاه اجانب الايراني من قبل الدول
الغربيه بشكل عام وهنالك الحقيقه نشهد بعض
التغيرات في مواقف بعض الدول التي كانت
اقل حده في السابق الان على المستوى
الفرنسي على سبيل المثال نرى ان هنالك حده
في الخطاب الفرنسي اتجاه اجانب الايراني
وبالتالي ايران منخرطه في هذا الصراع لكن
يبدو ايضا ان ايران بهذه التصريحات
تصريحات امير عبد الحيان يعني بتعطي اشاره
الى الغرب بانها ما زالت متمسكه
ببصيص الامل في الاتفاق همم النووي وهو
الاتفاق الذي وصف بانه سينهار ان ثبت ان
ايران تزود روسيا
بتسوا ان الصواريخ البالستيه والمسيرات
ايضا حتى ايرانيه الصنع خلال هذه الازمه
فهل يمكن لايران ان تخاطر بملف الاتفاق
انه مع الدول الغربيه لتز طب روسيا بهذه
النوعيه من الاسلحه برايك سيد رامي
باعتقادي نعم بالنسبه لجانب الايراني لا
يراهن كثيرا على مساله الاتفاق النووي كما
تعلم منذ وصول رئيسي الى سده الحكم وهنالك
تغير في موقف النظام الايراني بشكل عام من
هذا الاتفاق قبل ذلك كنا نشهد ان هنالك
الدفاع عن ايرانيه من اجل الوصول سريعا
الى توقيع هذا الاتفاق او العوده مره اخرى
الى هذا الاتفاق ولكن منذ ان جاءت الاداره
الجديده الايرانيه واشهدنا انه هنالك
تباطؤا في التفاعل مع المفاوضات وان هنالك
كثير من العقبات بدا يضعها النظام
الايراني هذا من جهه اخرى النظره الى
العلاقه مع روسيا هي النظره مختلفه
بالنسبه لنظام الايراني لا تربطها
بالاتفاق النووي لان ترى ان تلك علاقاتها
علاقات استراتيجيه خصوصا في ملفات معينه
كما تعلم نايف هنالك تنسيق ايراني روسي
فيما يتعلق بالملف السوري فيما يتعلق في
قضايا متعلقه بالشرق الاوسط والوجود
الايراني في سوريا والتي تعتبرها
واسطه العقد في نفوذها في المنطقه ياتي
بالتوافق والتفاهم مع اجانب الروسي
وبالتالي هذه مساله استراتيجيه واكثر
اهميه بالنسبه لجانب الايراني من الاتفاق
النووي نقطه اخيره يسمح لي بالاشاره اليها
الاتفاق النووي يبدو انه يتعثر وخصوصا مع
الاداره الجديده او اداره وايضا التي لم
تعد متحمسه لهذا الاتفاق لاسباب كثيره
منها العلاقات الايرانيه الروسيه وبالتالي
باعتقاد ان ايران لا تراهن على الاقل في
هذه الفتره على ان هنالك امكانيه للوصول
سريعا الى الاتفاق النووي ولكن سواء الغرب
او الولايات المتحده او طهران كلاهما يريد
الحفاظ على شعره معاويه بمعنى يعلم انه لا
امكانيه الوصول الى الاتفاق ولكنه لا يريد
ان يقطع الطريق نهائيا على اتفاق وبالتالي
ذلك الهامش من الامل بامكانيه العوده الى
طاوله المفاوضات مره اخرى
وبالتالي ايضا يمكن السؤال هنا عن طرف اخر
في هذه الازمه تتحدث طبعا عن الاتفا نووي
وعن اسرائيل نتنياهو عاده مره اخرى الى
الواجهه السياسيه في اسرائيل اليوم تنقل
تصريحات همم عن عضو بالليكود للقناه
الثانيه عشر الاسرائيليه يقول بان نتنياهو
سيضرب منشات نوويه ايرانيه حاله فشلت
المحادثات في فيينا ايران باي عين تنظر
الى المعادله كامله باي عين تنظر ايضا الى
هذه التهديدات
الاسرائيليه فيما يتعلق بالعوده الى
الاتفاق النووي الذي قد ينهار بسبب تعاون
ايران مع روسيا وتزويدها ايضا حتى
بالصواريخ والمسيرات الايرانيه
اتحدث عن الشق الاول من سؤالك وهو المتعلق
باسرائيل الحقيقه ان اسرائيل كان لها
تاثير كبير في عرقله الوصول الى اتفاق
لانها لا تثق
والنظام الايراني والحقيقي عدد من دول
المنطقه لا يثق بنظام الايراني ومشكلتهم
مع ايران ليست فقط الملف النووي كما تعلم
ولكن هنالك ملفات اخرى في المنطقه الان
بالنسبه للموقف الاسرائيلي يمكن ان يذهب
بعيدا في الحرب الاستخباراتيه كما كان
سابقا ويمكن ان يذهب ايضا بعيدا في
استهداف المواقع الايرانيه الموجوده في
سوريا القواعد العسكريه الموجوده هنالك
وايضا يمكن ان يكون هنالك حرب سبرانيه مع
النظام الايراني لكن الدخول في مواجهه
مفتوحه واطلاق صواريخ بشكل مباشر من
اسرائيل تستهدف مواقع النوويه باعتقاد هذا
الامر مستمعه حتى الان وهذا الامر يحتاج
الى غطاء سياسي امريكي وهذا غير متوفر حتى
الان بالرغم من ان هناك تصريحات واضحه من
الاداره الامريكيه انها ليست معنيه
بالوصول يعني الى الاتفاق مع اجانب
الايراني لكن ايران عفوا الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ما تزال ترفض ان يكون هنالك عمل
عسكري اسرائيلي مباشر ضد جانب الايراني
وحتى الان يوجد رغبه امريكيه بعدم
الانزلاق الى عمل العسكري مع ايران
معك هلا يمكن
ان يعطي هذا الامر
سياسيا لاسرائيل فيما لو ثبت فعلا ان
ايران زودت همم روسيا او ستزودها بالمزيد
من الصواريخ بالمزيد من المسيرات ايضا في
حربها في اوكرانيا
القرار ليس الاسرائيليه في نهايه المطاف
القرار قرار الامريكي كمواجه مفتوحه لان
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تدرك بان هذه
الحرب في حال اندلعت لن تبقى في حدود
الصراع ما بين اسرائيل والجانب الايراني
في اطار استهداف مواقع معينه ولكن
المواجهه الشامله سوف تضطر الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه الى الدخول فيها وضع
اعتقادي ان الولايات المتحده ليست معنيا
بالدخول في هذه المواجهه على الاقل في هذا
التوقيت ولكن في حال ثبوت همم بالفعل
تصدير طائرات مسيره وهذا ثبت بالنسبه
للدوائر الغربيه باعتقالي ان ذلك سوف يعقد
الوصول الاتفاق نووي سوف يزيد العقوبات
الغربيه اتجاه الجانب الايراني وسوف يمنع
الوصول الى تفاهمات ايرانيه امريكيه على
الاقل كما كانت تامن اداره وايضا وكما كان
يعمل ايضا النظام الايراني اشكرك جزيل
الشكر من باريس عندما المحلل السياسي رمي
خليفه
نبقى في ذات الشان حيث ادانت وزاره
الخارجيه الاوكرانيه بشده قيمه روسيا
بعمليات ترحيل مواطنين اوكرانين يعيشون في
الاراضي المحتله مؤقتاصفها في منطقه خرسون
وزبوريجيا في اوكرانيا وكده الخارجيه
الاوكرانيه وجوده اجراءات
لنقل قصرين جماعي لسكان منطقه خرسون
لاسيما مقاطعه اسكادو فيسكو وزبوري جاء
ولو كانسكو
جزيره القرم وتحدثت الخارجيه الاوكرانيه
عن وجود تقارير مقلقه ايضا حول قيام
القوات الروسيه في تلغيمه
الكهرومائيه والتي قد يتسبب تفجيرها في
كارثه انسانيه واسعه النطاق
اعلنت شركه الكهرباء الحكوميه الاوكرانيه
عن قطع التيار الكهربائي جدول محدد في كيف
وسبع مناطق اخرى في البلاد في اعقاب
الضربات الروسيه المدمره على البنيه
التحتيه للطاقه تاتي هذه الخطوه في الوقت
الذي تواصل فيه القوات الروسيه قصف المدن
الاوكرانيه بالصواريخ والطائرات المسيره
الحلقه اضرارا بمحطات الطاقه وامدادات
المياه وبين التحتيه اخرى
فيما تتواصلوا الاحتجاجات ضد النظام
الايراني اعلن الطلاب جامعه مختلفه في
ايران انهم سيضربون عن حضور الفصول
الدراسيه حتى اطلاق سراح الطلاب المسجونين
وتحسين الوضع الامني في البلاد وكانت طلاب
جامعه طهران قد اعلنوا في بيان انهم
سيقاطعون الفصول الدراسيه مره اخرى
واجلسون في الكليه اعتبارا من يوم السبت
14 من نوفمبر في الاسابيع الاخيره همم
بدلته قوه الامن في هذه الاسابيع في
الجمهوريه الايرانيه كل جهودها لقمع
الاحتجاجات في عموم البلاد لا سيما في
الجامعه
افاده قناه ايران انترناشونال بمقتل 16
شخصا تحتجاجات في مدينه خاشقجي البلاد
والتي اندلعت امس الجمعه ونقلتها القناه
عن مولاوي عبد الحميد امام اهل السنه في
ايران قوله ان القوات الامن الايرانيه
تعاملت بعنف مع الاحتجاجات في المدينه
الواقعه بمحافظه سيستان وبلوشيستان وكانت
القناه ذكرت ان قوات الامن الايرانيه
اطلقت الرصاص على محتجين في مدينه خاش
واصفهان ما اسفر عن سقوط قتلى وجرحى في
صفوف المتظاهرين
ابهرت الصور لاستمرار التظاهرات ليلا في
عدد من المدن الايرانيه حيث رفع المئات من
المحتجين شعارا الموت للديكتاتور في مطارد
المحتجون قوات الامن في مدينه الخلخال في
محافظه اردبيل
سلام الجميل
دي اسمها ايه
قيمه العمله الايرانيه تنخفض مقابل
الدولار
الامريكي جراء الاحتجاجات المستمره في مدن
عده ولاول مره في تاريخ الاقتصاد الايراني
تكسر العمله الامريكيه حاجزه سته
36,800 مقابل الدولار الواحد
الرابعه مستمره تتابعون فيها بعد قليل
ايضا
القوات الجويه السعوديه تصل الى قاعده
سوده اليونانيه للمشاركه في تمرين عسكري
المشترك
حياكم الله من جديد في السعوديه كشف وكيل
التوطين بوزاره الموارد البشريه والتنميه
الاجتماعيه
اكثر من مليون
و850,000 وثيقه عمل منذ اطلاقا منصه العمل
الحر
حتى نهايه الربع الثالث من العام الجاري
مشيرا الى تسجيل اكثر من مليون و650 الف
عامل حر خلال الفتره ذاتها الضحوي اوضح
انه تم ادراج اكثر من 270 مهنه في منصه
العمل الحر بشراكه مع 11 جهه حكوميه
واشرفيه
ينضم الينا في الاستديو المختص في الموارد
البشريه اسامه الشمريسي مرحبا بك معي في
النشره الرابعه من الرياض اولا
انا اليوم على سبيل المثال امتلك وثيقه
العمل الحر ما الذي يمكن ان تعطيني اياه
من مزايا لماذا اصلا انا اريد ان استخرج
هذه الوثيقه
في البدايه امسي عليكم
مشاهدات الكرام احنا لو اعطينا بس نبدا
بسيطه برنامج وثيقه العمل الحر هو احد
برامج وزاره الموارد البشريه التنميه
الاجتماعيه وهو مبادره اطلقت الحقيقه منذ
ثلاث سنوات وهو يعتبر من احد
برامج رؤيه المملكه 2030 والهدف منها هو
تنظيم
عمل اليه العمل الحر والاستفاده من جميع
الخبرات ممكنه والعمل على المستوى الشخصي
اللي هو يعتبر على المستوى الافراد اذا
تكلمنا عن هذه الاهداف الرئيسيه الحقيقه
من توثيق
وثيقه الحصول على وثيقه العمل الحر اذا
احنا نتكلم عن استقلاليه تامه ونتكلم عن
توثيق الخبره او الهوايه وتعتبر وثيقه
العمل الحر الحقيقه هي باكوره الدخول الى
القطاع الخاص
والانخراط في قطاع الاعمال بشكل شخصي
والاستفاده من جميع الخدمات التي تقدم دون
التقييد الحقيقه في عمل مرتبط في اي قطاع
من القطاعات الموجوده في
كانها سجل تجاري بس للافراد دون شكل
الحقيقه هي همم هناك فرقات
احنا نتكلم
يعني اهم فروقات انك انت تعمل كوثيقه تعمل
حره على مستوى الشخصي اذا انت لا تتقيد
بالشروط والمعايير المطلوبه في السجل
التجاري كذلك الرسوم المطلوبه ودفعها
واستخراجها
وتحصيلها من بعض الجهات تطلب في حال الح
كاس جل التجاري الى اخر بينما وثيقه العمل
الحر وانت تتكلم عن استقلال كيان شخصي
مستقل مرتبط فيه هوايتك وتحوير هذه وتحويل
هذه الهويه الحقيقه الموجوده لك الى هويه
فعليه الى عامل مؤسساتي يوجد منها بشكل
رئيسي توثيق
وتحديد هذه المهام وابراز العمل التي
تقدمه بناء على وثيقه العمل الحر بالاضافه
الى توثيق العمل المؤسسه شبيهه للعمل
المؤسسات بحصولك على حساب بنك مستقبل على
حصولك وثيقه العمل الحر بالاضافه انه
والاهم منها الحقيقه هو الاستقلاليه
والعمل على المستوى الشخصيه عمل حر همم
يصبح عندك حساب بنك خاص بحامل هذه الوثيقه
ومن خلال اي ما بقى تدخل الى حسابك يعني
من خلال هذه الهوايه اللي تكون فيها وثيقه
العمل الحر اللي انت مقدم عليها في نفس
التخصص همم تكون موجوده من هذا الحساب
الحساب البنكي ما في مشكله مش الحساب
الشخصي لا لا مش الحساب الشخصي وهذا هذا
هذا الهدف الرئيس اللي احنا تكلمنا عليه
ومن ضمن الاهداف كذلك هو هو ليس بهدف واحد
لاطلاق هذا البرنامج ومن ضمن هذا الاهداف
كذلك انه هو التوفيق ان في موثوقيه كذلك
باليه تعاملك مع القطاعات الاخرى او في
تقديم خدماتك سواء كان على القطاع
المؤسسات نسوان على قطاع الشخصي سواء على
قطاع الاعلانات ايا يكون في عقود لابد ان
يكون في عقود لتكون هي مرجعيه بالفصل في
حال وجود نزال لا سمح الله المستقلين
وكذلك الى التحويل هذا
المنهجيه الى العمل المؤسسات منظم الحقيقه
كذلك للطرف الاخر حينما نتعاقد مع شخص او
هو مقدم خدمات اسوان عبر منصات الموجوده
عبر الانترنت الموثوقه وتحت مظله رئيسيه
او عن طريقه التواصل بشكل مباشر انه هناك
فعلا في كيان فردي مستقل تماما اذا في
موسيقيه من كل الطرفين خلينا نحكي على
الجانب الاخر وش همم الاشكاليات في
استخراجها
الحقيقه اشكاليات تذكر يعني بشكل مباشر
يعني على المستوى الشخصي انا قمت في بحث
الحقيقه على على مستوى وس- التواصل
الاجتماعي وكذلك على مستوى
المواقع الرسميه اللي هي تقدم هذه الخدمات
ونسبه الردود في خدمه العملاء لشكاوي بعض
الموظفين وثيقه العمل الحر اول ما اطلقت
كان المستهدف منها ان يصل الى عدد 150,000
مشتركه يعني ان يشترك فيها او ان يحصل على
هذا الوثيقه 850 الان احنا وصلنا الى
مليون 850 اذن مليون و850 دقيقه وهذا يعطي
مؤشر كبير لانه هناك كفاءات وهناك الحقيقه
خبره وهناك يعني احترافيه موجوده ترغب في
توثيقها في القطاع الخاص وكذلك ترغب في
زياده دخلها وكذلك هي هي تبتعد عن همم ثقل
البطاله او البحث عن العمل واستقلاليه في
داخل هام جدا اذا تتكلم احنا عن هذه
الجزئيات الرئيسيه والمرتبطه في وثيقه
الحر لابد ان يكون والتطوير لهذا البرامج
خلال الفتره الثلاث سنوات السابقه قد يكون
ابرزها الحقيقه المشاكل التي تواجه كانت
تكون مشاكل تقنيه تطوير في في اليه
استخراج والحصول على الترخيص قد يكون بعض
المتطلبات غير متوفره الحقيقه بمن يرغب
بالحصول على وثيقه العمل الحر ولكن هو
يمتلك الهويه ولكن هناك اشتراطات ومعايير
في حاله عدم استفتاءها دون شك انه العمل
المؤسسات والعمل منظم لابد ان يكون
الحقيقه مستوفي جميع الشرور
شكرا جزيلا لك انضم للسيد المختص البشريه
سيد اسامه الشمري شكرا لك الله يسلمك
اعلانات وزاره الداخليه السعوديه عن ضبط
اكثر من 16 الف مخالفه لانظمه الاقامه
والعمل والحدود خلال اسبوع في مختلف
المناطق كما تم ضبطه 23 متورط في نقل
وايواء وتشغيل المخالفين الوزاره كشفت
كذلك عن ترحيل اكثر من تسعه الاف مخالف
واحاله نحو الفين اخرين لاستقبال حجوزات
سفرهم الداخليه السعوديه شددت في بيانها
على ايقاع عقوبات مشدده بحق كل من يسهل
دخول المخالفين او يقوموا بنقلهم وتوفير
الماوى لهم حيث تصلوا العقوبات الى السجن
لمده 15 عاما
وغرامه ماليه تصل الى مليون ريال
وصلت مجموعه القوات الجويه السعوديه
المشاركه في مناورات تمرين عين الصقر
ثلاثه الى قاعده سود الجويه في جزيرتي
اليونانيه حيث من المقرر ان تنطلق
المناورات الاسبوع المقبل والتي تشارك
فيها القوات السعوديه بطائره مقاتله من
طرازي اف 15 مع كامل اطقمها الجويه
والفنيه والمسانده
في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه كشفت صحيفه
تويتر قبل اربعه ايام من انتخابات التجديد
النصفي بينهم اعضاء يعملون في الانتخابات
او على الانتخابات الامريكيه وتعديم
التعديل المحتوى على منصه التواصل
الاجتماعي واخرون في السياسه العامه فيما
قال ماسكينه لا يوجد امامه خيار اخر خاصه
عندما تخسر شركه اكثر من اربعه ملايين
دولار في اليوم جانبها قالت فوكس نيوز ان
الموتور هنا من تويتر سيرفعون دعوه ضد
ماسك فمن عمليه الطرد تنتهي كل قانونا في
ترالي مشيره الى ان القانون
الفيدرالي يلزمه باشعار الموظفين بالطرد
بعد اسبوع من صفقه شراء تويتر
من باريس الخبير في القانون الدولي مجيد
بوداس سيد مجيد مساء الخير مرحبا بك معي
في نشره الرابعه من الرياض عين القانون
كيف تقيم وتنظر الى هذه الخطوه خطوه لهن
ماسك لتسريح 50% من موظفين منصه
تويتر وهل انتهى كفعلا القانون فيدرالي
الامريكي
يعني المساله فيها عده جوانب ولكن بالاخير
همم لما يقع شراء الشركه من مستكبرين جدد
يكون لهم برنامج لاصلاح تلك الشركه وخاصه
في هذه في حاله التويتر انها تخسر اربع
مليون دولار يوميا وبالتالي لا يمكن
لمستثمرين ان يبقوا على الوفائيه مهما
كانت ولكن عليهم واجب احترام القوانين
واحترام القوانين ان ينذروا العمال الذين
الذين
يقع قفزهم وان وقع ولكن لهم الامكانيه
بفسدهم همم وان لم يحترم هذه الاجال فيجب
عليهم ان يعودوا على ذلك ولكن لا يمكن
منعهم من تسريحه بعد العمال لانقاذ الشركه
والانقاذ العمال الاخرين لان الشركه في
المفهوم القانوني ليست
الناس ليست مؤسسه خيريه لا يمكن التمادي
في همم ضخم الاجور بدون همم بدون همم ان
يقع اسلاح الشركه لذا فان الموضوع هو
موضوع قانوني بحث ومن الناحيه القانونيه
سيقع تعويدها هؤلاء الناس بشكل عادي طيب
اسال هنا عن يعني نحن نعلم ان ايل الناس
قرر اغلاق الكثير من مكاتب المنصه في عدد
كبير من دول العالم واسال انا هنا عن
عن العشق القانوني يعني انت تعلم بان ان
انظمه العمل تختلف من دوله من امريكا الى
فرنسا الى الشرق الاوسط الى غيره من الدول
بقاع الارض بهذا الاختلاف في انظمه العمل
والعمال هل يمكن
ان يعني دعنا نقول يصعب هذه العمليه
وبالتالي ممكن ان ترفع عدد من الدعاوى ان
يعوض ماسكه اولي الموظفين بقيمه ربما
تعادل او تتجاوز القيمه التي اشترى فيها
منصه تويتر
يعني تعدد مواقع العمل في وانظمه حمايه
العمال هي حسب البلد ولكن بالاخير مهما
كان البلد فسي الى المسك وتويتر لان الذي
فصل هو هي شركه تويوتا ستقوم بهذه
التعويذات وغلق هذه المكاتب وغلق هي عمليه
لاصلاح لاصلاح شركه تويتر لان اشتراها
بسعر مرتفع جدا ويجب عليه ان تكون هناك
مردوديه لانه يجب تسديد القروض التي اشترى
بها وهي 44 مليار دولار ومن هنا ستكون
ستكون هناك عديد من القضايا توفى في كل
بلد فيه مكتب من مكاتب تويتر
لا يمكن حسبه تقديرات انت ان تفوق مبالغ
هذه المبالغ ستكون تقديرات مهمه ولكن هذه
التقديرات هي موجوده في حساب ااا
الى الموسكي لما قام باشتراء تويتر وهي
مثل مثلا واضحه لذا المساله من ناحيه
الانسانيه هي مؤلمه لكثير من الناس الذي
وقع فسدهم ولكن هذه
القانوني والوضع الاقتصادي عليه له الحق
في فصل لذلك ولا هم الحق في ان تكون لهم
تعويذات عادله اشكرك جزيل السكر من باريس
الخبير في القانون الدولي شكرا لك
وقوف المرشحين على المنصه والاداء
بخطاباتهم امام الناخبين الجزء الظاهر من
المشهد غير ان كواليس العمليه تديرها
ماكينات انتخابيه يحكمها المال السياسي
فحجمه الانفاق على الحملات الانتخابيه في
الولايات المتحده يفوقوا احيانا الناتج
المحلي لبعض الدول
تمويل الحملات الانتخابيه وكيفيه ادارتها
وقود معركه اي مرشح للتاثير في الناخبين
والوصول الى الكونغرس او البيت الابيض
وفي وقت لا يحق لاي شخص او جهه اجنبيه
لاسهام بتمويل المرشحين يتيح القانون
للحاصلين على اقامه رسميه في الولايات
المتحده التبرع مساهمه متبرعين الصغار
وصلت الى نحو 22 في المئه من اجمالي
النفقات على الحملات الانتخابيه قبل عامين
نسبه فقد قليله التمويل الذاتيه من جانب
المرشحين والمقدر بسبعه عشر في المئه
اما الصيد الثمين فيتمثل برجال الاعمال
واصحاب المليارات الذين يلقون بثقالهم
المالي وراء حملات مرشحهام قدم مئه وواحد
131 مليارديرا منهم تبرعاتهم لبيض في
سباقه ضد ترامب لحفل مجلات الفوركس
ضخوا الاموال يتم ايضا عبر لجان عمل
سياسيا معروفه بباك تجمع التبرعات وتقدمها
لحملات المرشحين مباشره مع تحديد قيمه
الاموال المسموح بانتقالها بخمسه الاف
دولار لكل لجنه
فيما ثاني اللجان مستقله وهي سوبر باك
وتشارك في انفاق الاموال لغرض سياسي غير
محدود مثل الاعلانات ودفع الناخبين
المترددين لكن بشكل مستقل عن حملات
المرشحين
جدل متواصل حول نزاهه تمويل الحملات
الانتخابيه وتاثير وسائل التواصل الا ان
حجم الانفاق على الحملات ليس معيار دقيقا
لتحديد الفائزين
قد يتسبب ارتفاع سعر الوقود في امريكا الى
الايطاحه بالديمقراطيين من الكونجرس
حيثؤكد استطلاع لاي بي سي نيوز انه توجد
علاقه بين اسعار الغاز ومدام الرضا على
الرئيس السيسي وحزبه
الشجاعيه
الرابعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل ايضا
توقعاتكم بحاله مطريه على عدد من مناطق
السعوديه خلال الاسبوع القادم
حياكم الله من جديد كشفت اكاديميه طويق
التابعه للاتحاد السعودي للامن السيبراني
على حسابها في تويتر عن تجاوز عدد
المتدربين خلال اسبوع واحد فقط
اكاديميه الى بناء قدرات وطنيه واحده
وتطوير مهاراتها وقدراتها الفنيه والتقنيه
بتوفير محتوى تدريبين مكثف تم تطويره من
قبل المختصين وشركه الرائده في عده مجاله
انطلقت اليوم السبت نسخه الثانيه من مسيره
كات ووك العالميه احدى مبادرات مؤسسه كات
موسفيره التي اسستها الاميره ريما بنت
بندر سفيره السعوديه لدى الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه المبادره تهدف التي تقام طبعا
في جميع المناطق السعوديه تهدف لممارسه
المشي مسافه سبعه كيلومترات ورفع الوعي
باهميه الحفاظ على القطط البريه بالاضافه
لتصليه الضوء على نقاط التقاء بين مبادئ
صحه العامه والمحافظه على الطبيعه عبر
الربط بين القطاعات والمجتمع بطرق فعاله
ومؤثره
من فعاليات مبادره كات ووك بالدرعيه ينضم
الينا مراسل العربيه عبد المحسن الحربي
عبد المحسن مساء الخير مرحبا بك معي في
نشره الرابعه من الرياض اول شيء خلي
يناسبك شاركت فيها المبادره والمسيره ولا
لا يا عبد المحسن
والله المبادره بدات قبل نصف ساعه كنت
انتظر الهواء عشان كذا ما شاركت ولا كان
المفروض انا معاهم في المسيره اللي بدات
في تقريبا عند الرابعه والرابعه خمسه
دقائق لبعض من المشاركين وصل الى نهايه
همم
مسيره حيث نتواجد هنا في بالقرب من مطل
البجيري وهذه تقريبا نايف اول فعاليته قام
بقرب مطالب جيري بعد اعاده تاهيله
وهممينه او تدشينه خلال ربما الاشهر
القادمه لكن الان نتحدث عن هذه المباراه
التي تقام بالقرب منه وهيكاتورك همم اكثر
من 500 مشارك ربما تشاهد بالقرب من
المنطقه هنالك اجواء احتفاليه بعد
الانتهاء من المسيره المسيره شارك فيها ما
يقارب 500 او اكثر من 500 شخص تنوعه ما
بين مسؤولين حكوميين وكلاء وزراء
واعيان للمجتمع وحتى المشاركين والمهتمين
همم عمليات المحافظه على
همم البيئه وكذلك المحافظه على القطط
البريه حيث ان هذه المبادره اسست من قبل
مؤسسه كاتمو سفير التي اسستها الاميره
ريما بنت بندر بن سلطان في العام الماضي
في الولايات المتحده وهي الان في السعوديه
تنتشر في اكثر من منطقه همم الحقيقه عند
قدوم المشاركين الى همم الدخول في هذه
المسيره يتم همم تخيرهم المسيره ستكون
لاحدى القطط البريه السبع التي تم وضعها
وكل واحد منهم حمل صوره لهذه القطط البريه
نتحدث عن الفهد نمر الثلج والنمر العربي
والاسد والبر واسد الجبال
وكذلكور وكل هذه الحيوانات او القطط
البريه مهدده بالانقراض همم حيث يسير
هؤلاء مشاركين في هذه المسيره وسط اجواء
رائعه همم نايف في همم بالقرب من مطار
البديري شارك في هذه الاحتفاليه الرئيس
التنفيذي لهيئه تطوير بوابه الدرعيه وهناك
عدد من المشاركين الاخرين ايضا من مختلف
ال- اا فئات همم المجتمع ايضا همم الهيئه
تقول بان هذه همم هذه الفعاليه التي
تستضيفها بالتعاون مع المؤسسه التابعه
للاميره ريما بنت بندر بن سلطان سفيره
السعوديه لدى الولايات المتحده بان هذه
المبادراته من خلالها الهيئه الى تعزيز
الصحه تعزيز الرياضه وايضا المشاركه
المجتمعيه
وجعل مطل البجيري وكل منشات الدرعيات همم
المبادرات البيئيه التي يشارك فيها
المجتمع في الحقيقه بدات بالتزامن هذه
الفعاليه مع همم انطلاقات اخرى في مختلف
مناطق المملكه تنظمها هذه همم المؤسسه
للمحافظه او لتوعيه بالمحافظه على القطط
السبعه التي تحدثت عنها قبل قليل نايف
الشكر عبد المحسن على كل هذه المعلومات
والتفاصيل من مبادره كانت واقعيه ضميرينا
مراسل العربيه عبد المحسن الحربي توقع
المركز السعودي للارصاد ان تشهد اجزاء من
مناطق تبوك والجوف والحدود الشماليه وحائل
والمدينه ومكه والشرقيه والقصيم حاله
ممطره تبدا بنهايه الاسبوع القادم وقد
يمتدروا تاثيرها الى الاجزاء الساحليه
لتلك المناطق
تنظم وهيئه التراث مسابقه بيوت عسير
الملونه الموجهه لمختلف الفئه العمريه
وذلك خلال الفتره من الثلاثين من اكتوبر
الى الخامس من نوفمبر بهدف ابراز الفنون
التراثيه العريقه التي عرفت بها منطقه
عسير المرتبطه بالزخارف والالوان في
العماره المحليه للمنطقه التفاصيل محمد
خالد
وسط اجواء بارده تميزت بها محافظه الحرجه
بمنطقه عسير يعيش الاهالي حدث مميز تنظمه
هيئه التراث تحت عنوان بيوت عصير الملونه
لاظهار الزخارف والالوان في العماره
المحليه للمنطقه
قصور الاثريه
والحمد لله بفضل الله سبحانه وتعالى
وصلت الفكره الى الوزاره
وتم اعاده ترميمها
بيوت اسير ملونه من ضمن بيوت عسيري
الملونه الرحاله الوالد بدايه من عام يمكن
1399 بدي سيارات وكان معجب في
النقش
يعني نقش المنطقه
الاثري فكان يزور الوالد ولما يزور الوالد
طال عمرك واعجب
بالصور
احد المعارض وعندي انا صوره له لما نزار
في عام 1399 وكانت يعني من خلف الصوره كان
كاتب عليها يعني اشاده بالوالد ابنها كان
متعاونه
تتضمن المسابقه وتلوين سبعه بيوت مختلفه
في قريه ال مسلم وادي جناب بمحافظه الحرجه
على مدى سته ايام كمتقدم للزوار فعاليات
تحكي تاريخه وتراث هذه البيوت السبعه
اضافه الى منطقه مساحات لونيه تراثيه يعيش
من خلالها الضيوف تجربه مليئه بالتنوع
البصري والحسيه
في محافظه على الاصاله وعلى التراث
الالوان جميع الالوان الاساسيه في تراثنا
وفي في الاشياء التراثيه في نفس النقش
الجنوبي والقطه العسيري همم حافظين الحمد
لله عليهم ما نزلنا الا نعمل لها نستغلها
في كتطوير وفي بتستخدمها في الحقائب وفي
الشناط وفي الطفشات وفي القبعات في
الاشياء هذه يعني الحمد لله الشعور جدا
لا يوصف جدا سعيد بهذا الحدث
بعده معالم سياحيه موجوده فيها وعده تاريخ
المكان اللي تواجد الان فيه يعتبر فيه
ميزه تاريخيه الاحد الرحالين زار المكان
وثق فيه لكن خلينا نتكلم عن الفاعليه من
وزاره الثقافه جدا جميله في عمليه
التفاصيل في عمليه اختيار
الحرف الموجوده من حيث البناء التلوين
الزخرفه على همم بعض الاواني المستخدمه
همم
جميله
تاتي مسابقه هيئه التراث بهدف ابراز
الفنون التراثيه العريقه التي عرفت بها
منطقه عسير والتي تعد عنصرا اساسيا في
تزيين الورقه المنازل سابقا كما انها تعمق
مداه اهميه الفنون البصريه لدى الاجيال
الحاضره لمحافظه الحرج محمد خالد العربيه
نظم الوفد الدائم للمملكه العربيه
السعوديه لدى اليونسكو في مقر اليونسكو في
باريس عرضا للفيلم الوثائقي الفرنسي
المذاق العربي والذي تدور احداثه حول رحله
طاهيين فرنسيين شهيرين الى جده
عن سر المذاق العربي تدور احداث الفيلم
الوثائق الفرنسي سافوغدا غبي الذي عرض في
مقر اليونسكو في باريس بدعوه من الوفد
الدائم للسعوديه الفيلم يروي حكايات رحله
استكشافيه لطهيان شهيرين عالميا قرر زياره
السعوديه للتعارف على ثقافه مجتمعه ومطبخه
العريق اليوم سعيده بان يكون موجوده
ونقدم هذا الفيلم الوثائقي الدول الاعضاء
في اليونسكو هذا في المثليقه ايضا يعرض
ناحيه اخرى وهي المواقع المسجله في قائمه
يذكر التراث العالمي مثل جده القديمه مثل
الحجر في العلارونا هو ان نوضح الصوره
الحقيقيه للمملكه للعالم واعتقد اليوم
وثائقي كان خطوه جيده في هذا المجال
يلا يلا
خصوصيه الرحله لم تكن محصوره باستكشاف
الطعام بل ايضا الاماكن التراثيه حيث
اختارت طاهيان الفرنسيان جده والعلا
التاريخيتين كنقطتين انطلاقا وبدات
مسيرتهما عبر رحله بحريه تخللها صيد في
البحر الاحمر وزياره لسوق السمك المركزي
فضلا عن التجول في المنطقه التاريخيه بجده
وحول ابرز معالم العلا
قه
ليتشارك معهم تجاربهم سعدت جدا بزياره
السعوديه حيث اكتشفت الكثير من المنتجات
والماكولات الفريده وقبل كل شيء سعيد
لانني التقيت باشخاص رائعين
ورشيديه
التي استمرت 10 ايام نظره اجمل عن المملكه
العربيه السعوديه
وثقافتها واهميه مواقعها التراثيه
بحث عن النكهات العربيه الاصيله اخترته
يعني فرنسيان شهيران ان يحطوا رحالهما في
السعوديه ووثقه من خلال مشاركتهما في هذا
الفيلم الوثائقي مغامره شيقه قدم من
خلالها نظره جديده عن المملكه وتراثها
الثقافي زينه عادي العربيه باريس
نقلا عن مسؤولين غربيين قناه سي ان ان
تقولوا ان ايران تستعدوا لارسال المزيد من
المسيرات لروسيا
الحكومه الاوكرانيه تعلن عن قطع مجدول
للكهرباء في العاصمه وسبع مناطق اخرى بسبب
الضربات الروسيه
الداخليه السعوديه تعلن ضبطه ترحيل اكثر
من 25 الف مخالفا للانظمه خلال اسبوع
نحوي مليونير وثيقه عمل حر في السعوديه
الرابعه تفتحوا ملف عوائق اصدارها والعمل
بها
اختتام ومسابقه بيوت عسير الملونه بعد
خمسه ايام من انطلاقها بعصير جنوب
السعوديه
نهايه الرابع الى اللقاء